so far we learned about bioinformatics
research in indian industries now let us
see what is the present status of
bioinformatics in africa in terms of
education internship job opportunities
and research i would like to welcome
miss
patmaio
who works as the bioinformatics team
leader at the center for proteomic and
genomic research and works fifty percent
of a time as the bioinformatics
coordinator at diplomats a cpgr grant
program her main role is in overseeing
efforts to develop different methods to
understand data generated from the
different omics fiends the organization
sir she also enjoys learning new
concepts from managing these projects in
these roles she has aided or led in
building successful products and
complete projects
this has
this has refined her marketing project
product and team management skills she
has enjoyed and has found that a
strength is in diligently stitching the
different components needed to deliver
successful services
she is also pursuing her phd program
which looks to explore factors that
contribute to developing competencies in
the evolving biomedical field that
experiences a constant change of scope
in work like at the cpgr
ultimately to improve on products and
outcomes which attracts funding in
business to continue to boost with a
particular focus on work done in africa
that was indeed an introduction though
now i would like to welcome miss
fardmail over to you
thank you very much uh let me just share
my
screen
can you see my presentation
yes we can see us perfect
yeah perfect okay okay so thank you for
that introduction so i'll get right into
it
um i'll start off with the cpgr and i'll
explain how
the two other organizations fit into
this
so here's a summary of
where everything sits so uh the
department of science and innovation in
south africa funds different programs
and one of them is the technology
innovation agency which funds the cpgr
which is my primary employer
and the other two organizations that i'm
going to speak about are diplomix which
is a program so the cpgr hosts that and
the cpgr
also has a subsidiary startup which is
called artist environment
so in these different organizations um
that's where the different sort of
titles come out so in diplomacy i'm a
bioinformatics coordinator at the cpg
i'm the bioinformatics team leader and
at artisan i'm a bioinformatics
consultant
so all of these um
although are connected are quite
independent and have different visions
so it's quite interesting to be in
either of them then i'll touch a little
bit more about what i do in them i'll
strictly be focusing on the
bioinformatics aspect of of each one of
them but they actually do quite a lot so
if you're interested in learning a
little bit more about then you're
welcome to contact me
so i'll start off with the ctgr
so the cpgr stands for center for
proteomic and genomic research and it is
a non-profit organization that i
mentioned is funded by the department of
science and innovation in south africa
through one of the programs called
tia so that's a technology innovation
agency so we sit in woodstock in cape
town in south africa
it works mainly in the model of a
contract research organization so
focus is on different services and
training
it is omix
focused so omix research and life
science innovation in africa
so the main omics fields that it focuses
on it offers comprehensive services in
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
metabolomics and bioinformatics
so it houses uh quite a lot of
world-class infrastructure so the
organization itself has a wide range of
instruments
so if you'd like to know a lot more
about the different
instruments that are at the cpgr they
have an unpacking the toybox series so
if you go to cpgr's linkedin you'll be
able to follow that series as they
explain each of the machinery that they
have
so the reason why i'm mentioning this
wide variety of capabilities is that
along with that we offer bioinformatics
support so in terms of the work that i
do for the cpgr it's a sort of in-house
support for uh all of the wide range of
services that could be offered um
through all of this machinery
okay so cpgr biomatic is an overview so
as i as i mentioned the projects that
happen
um in the lab can come through our
bioinformatics so it is an optional
service so if you need bioinformatics
support for any uh web lab services that
you get that's what we're there for
uh so
we have different clients so the
clientele is from industry and academia
but mostly from academia the clients are
researchers are students
consortiums so i gave here an example of
a consortium that we're a part of so
it's a big consortium called madcap so
men of african descent can cancel the
prostrate
and this is a custom array that was
created it is a project that is funded
by the nih so that would fall under
consortium and we also have commercial
clients that are either doing research
to better their product or their
offering or they're using our lab to run
some of their services
so in terms of the bioinformatics team
because we have a wide range of projects
that come in we don't although we have
standard pipelines we tailor make
each
product to each client whether they're
from research or
their commercial client we will tailor
make
um the solution that we make for them
the reason why we do this is because one
the clients are different too their
objectives are going to be different so
even if it's an rna-seq project each
client will want something different so
i will explain what i need now
after i explained uh the micro the
makeup of the bioinformatics team so the
bioinformatics team is made up of
biomedic bioinformatic analysts
so the skill set in terms of the people
that we hire is based on the analysis
that we do so it has to when we're
hiring someone it has a focus on
genomics and proteomics
it
the cp job being a cr also a contract um
contract research it means that you have
more defined turnaround times because
it's a service that you're offering
someone
unlike in academia where it's a research
project and you have for example a year
to complete your master the the
turnaround time is not as
strict and as defined
so the core skill that we
need for our bioinformation so this will
differ from organization to organization
it will differ from industry to industry
depending on what you're doing so when
i'm talking about core skill set i'm
talking about a core skill set that's
needed for you to be a bioinformatician
at the cpgr so here our core skill set
when we're hiring someone is programming
why because the main skill that's needed
to implement the solutions based on the
different services that we offer in the
lab
our core language we use python
why because it's easy to learn and easy
to use
we try to have a standard language that
everyone uses if you have another
language that you
you prefer or you're you're well versed
in we still welcome you because that may
be useful
um
additional fundamental requirements is
experience in r and bash because we also
do use that and some knowledge of
biology why because
most projects are very holistic you're
not only going to use piping sometimes
you'll need to use bash sometimes you'll
need to use art sometimes what's really
needed for the project is a good
understanding of the biology
so
all of these are important because we
also collaborate with the wet lab so
that's another good thing about the cpgr
is that all of this is housed under one
roof from the wet lab to the analysis so
a client will have
uh from start to finish and you can
actually go to the person in the lab and
they can even tell you that you can say
you know for example uh two i'm seeing
um that the qc is looking a bit fuzzy
and then the person in the lab can tell
you that oh you know what these are the
qc metrics and when i was handling it
they didn't send the aliquot was way
less than the other ones and i was just
trying to make it work so it helps you
understand the better the data a little
bit more so all of these skill sets are
needed uh because um we apply a holistic
approach to solving
problems
and then the bioinformatics platform or
department itself we work
collaboratively internally so as a team
we collaborate together if someone is
experiencing certain issues that's why i
i noted that it's important for us to at
least have common programming languages
or skill sets so that internally we can
collaborate and externally we
collaborate quite a lot with the clients
and with the wetlab
we have to make sure that we can
integrate to assist each other
so whatever system is in place it's
important for us to have a common
language as i said so that we can
integrate into the same system one of
the things that our platform or a
department has to consider is storage so
we have a lot of clients that come into
the cpgr we store their data we have to
consider how we're managing storage we
have to consider connectivity sometimes
we have cloud solutions or we have to um
upload or download databases so
connectivity is a big consideration
we have to consider high performance
computing so
as you all may know that some tools are
really computationally intensive and you
cannot do it on your laptop you would
need a high performance computer
you would also have to consider data
sharing platforms or methods um
because you also want to integrate
externally into a client system because
maybe they receive data in a certain way
so you would have to consider that a
very important one is you have to
consider code hosting platform we use
github so you have to make sure that
it's a very standardized um system at
the cpgr so they are iso credited which
means there's a standard way that you do
everything it makes it make sure that
you can always backtrack if you have a
problem um that things are reproducible
so one of the to fulfill one of those
requirements is we put all of our code
up on github it makes sure that um
anyone else can come and replicate it
um so yeah
that's an important consideration
you also need to consider tools and
software and related licenses
um so sometimes you only need the
license for one particular client so you
have to think that through to say how
will i complete this project so those
are the main considerations when setting
up a bioinformatics platform
and then bioinformatics is a service
so this is quite different from
academics
we've had bioinformatics analysts who
joined the team and they have their
testament to this to say that it's a
very uh different environment
when you are now offering bioinformatics
as a service it's a bit more refined um
you need to be a bit more sure about
what you're doing because it's helping
inform someone else's project or someone
else's service
um so the next time when i say a service
means an offering that requires a
specific result so when a client comes
in they want something specific at the
end so whatever you're doing you're
trying to get to that point
um in research uh if you sort of reach
certain blocks you can you know take
your time to think another way to do it
or to drop it when you're offering it as
a service the client expects a result at
the end
so you'll find that by informatics as a
service you employ quite a lot of
business principles um
with a high emphasis emphasis on human
capital so
in terms of my team i gear it mainly
towards soft skills you'll find very
quickly when you're offering
bioinformatics as a service that your
soft skills are going to be such a big
component so for example something as
little as communication whether you're
communicating internally as a team or
externally turned to a client you need
to communicate effectively because it
reduces scope creeps so scope creep is
um
the project slowly getting bigger and
bigger because people are slowly adding
requirements so you'll find with with um
clients who are researchers they're
quite excited about their project and
what they'll do is they'll come and say
oh can the data do this or can the data
do that or can we do this and can we do
that and that increases the the budget
the turnaround time um and it just
prolongs the project so if you learn how
to communicate effectively then that
sort of reduces scope creep so you'll
find that a lot of soft skills um have
to come in with your with your hard
skills so you have tighter more defined
deadlines so there's a little bit more
pressure in a service environment
so i think this environment works better
for individuals who enjoy
solving like varied problems so if you
enjoy solving some people enjoy looking
at a particular protein for the next 20
years and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that some people like looking
at proteins today and looking at genes
tomorrow and tomorrow looking at a
specific organism i think this
environment will work well for the
latter someone who likes um looking at
different problems and solving them and
being able to move on
um yeah
okay in terms of
service output
so
it's dependent on the client's
objectives so at the end of the day
uh when we're giving a client a result
if someone comes in usually this is what
we give them either we're giving them
data because they want the analysis done
to a certain point and they're going to
do downstream analysis by themselves so
some people might just say give me my
raw data some people might say qc my
data and then give it to me some people
might say
analyze the data up to a point where i
have your otus and then give it to me or
sometimes we do analysis and they will
interpret the results themselves um
sometimes we'll do analysis and training
because they would like to analyze
future data sets by themselves so
that's also for researchers who would
like who are continuing with their
project they might want you to do it the
first time and where if they get more
data then they might want to do training
so they can do it by themselves training
so you can train someone because they
would like to analyze their own data
sets from scratch um collaborative
which means that they would like the
client would like us to significantly
contribute to their project
so they would like us to analyze and
interpret and actually give results and
then include us in papers and so on
um
sometimes it's consulting so they would
like to build it themselves but just
need someone as a sounding board or
someone to check in with so they will
purchase let's say eight hours and then
two hours a week we have a meeting where
they take us through their solution so
here is just an example of um
training so we get a lot of inquiries
about rna-seq and we thought it would be
a good idea to have an educational
webinar where we just take people
through a basics of the analysis so that
they have an understanding of it and
sometimes when people understand it
better then they can say oh you know
what this will be too much for me and
i'd rather you do the analysis they can
make an informed decision about how you
want them to help you so from this
educational webinar some people will
come up and say actually this is too
much and i'd just like you to do the
analysis or some people would say oh
this looks manageable and i'd like to
take a stab at it so i would like to
take this consulting hour approach where
i go and i do it and then we meet every
week if i'm experiencing problems
um so those are the basic service
outputs at the cpgr
so now i'm going to move to diplomax
where i am a bioinformatics coordinator
so
diplomix as i mentioned let me just go
back to it it is hosted by the cpgr and
it's an infrastructure program
so the approach involves mainly
collaboration capacity development and
optimization and this requires amongst a
lot of things but partners experts and
cooperation from from my um point of
view and this is just a summary of what
diplomatics does so our aim is to build
world-class in omics infrastructure and
how do we do that it's either we're
placing instruments um and this is the
impact that it has and these are the
impacts so that they're going to be
direct induced and direct simulative and
over time you can sort of tell like an
indirect um
an indirect impact and and sorry i've
got a chat
an indirect um
impact
and then um enables access to students
and researchers and that's done in
various ways um so in terms of training
in terms of high visibility high impact
projects um and then the different
impacts are you know you get
world class reputational gain when you
do high impact high visibility projects
um
so
it speaks to our capability to to to do
things so if i link it back to what i'm
currently doing um for my phd now all of
these as i said are although they're
connected they have different focuses so
maybe just to speak about high
visibility high impact project for my
phd where i speak about um
once we have a good reputation of doing
reproducible and good um
doing research that has good outcomes
then we can have that reputational game
and gain and over time that will attract
funding or that will attract business so
that's like a cumulative or a long-term
impact but um as time goes on you'll see
the impact of it later so i'm going to
speak
uh about deponics again mainly um with
respect to bioinformatics but if you
guys have any
questions that relates to anything else
you can get in touch with me after
so diplomatics there are three omics
fields that it branches into so genomics
proteomics and metaphymics and
bioinformatics it is informed by a
working group of
experts and each has an overarching
domain expert who is the coordinator so
for example i am the bioinfomatics
coordinator and there is a
bioinformatics working group that has a
bioinformatics chair
um
and these different branches so genomics
proteomics and metabolomics and
bioinformatics who've had many
successful initiatives
so these initiatives range from either
training instrument placement and or
support for high impact initiatives so
you'll find here that for example
genomics would have a training outreach
or bioinformatics would have a training
outreach and then you develop skills or
you increase awareness of a particular
um
field or a particular technology and
then they're
different types of impacts that happen
over time
and then i'm going to talk about
bioinformatics
so information gathering is key to all
of our successful initiatives so before
we make a decision you sort of research
and say maybe this is the need or this
is the current situation and then you
sort of now research a little bit more
to be what is the best way to resolve it
so we would use this working group that
has all of these experts either as a
source or as a sound board or as a
source of initiatives themselves so of
the current needs with respect to
bioinformatics we have four main areas
of interest um so establishing
bioinformatics as a service improving
bioinformatics and project design
enabling or improving bioinformatics
training and inspiring the next
generation
so all of the above help improve
directly or indirectly overall outcomes
so
of the list that i've said here i'm just
going to expand a little bit more about
it so bioinformatics is service so we
launched clarity which is a
bioinformatics marketplace
um
it hosts expert bioinformatics
consultants who are managed by an
experienced concierge it is virtual
therefore it's accessible across across
the globe
um currently it subsidized to do
researchers to help establish it as the
service and its weight as a service so
it goes back to what we're talking about
building a reputation so that it either
attracts funding or attracts business
so that's one of the main reasons why
it's subsidized to researchers
we have a strong emphasis on good
project
because
design
have found in terms of
when we
are doing information gathering and
we're really talking about what are the
struggles people are having with
bioinformatics is that when they're not
doing the analysis they feel that the
bioinformatics is
failing them it's not necessarily that
the bioinformatics is failing is that if
you put a good data in then you'll get
good data out so if your data is not
it's not that the data is necessarily
bad but it's not the right data to
answer your research question so for
example your data may have passed in the
lab and the qc is good but if you're
trying to do whole exome sequencing or
you're trying to look for a variant and
you have rna-seq data it will answer
your question so it's the same way if
you haven't designed your project to get
the data that will help you answer the
question then you're always going to
find problems so that's why we have a
strong emphasis on good project design
so currently of the projects that have
come through our marketplace these are
mostly projects after data has been
produced which means that we would have
already passed the stage of project
design so we found that
clients may have
tried to take a stab at analyzing their
data and have found difficulties and
then now they'll go and find a service
provider and in that
um
other than just analyzing we're really
trying to roll back and get the best
that we can out of the project so again
this is also um
evidence supporting our initial uh
finding that project design is a really
important part of this um considering
bioinformatics that project design is
very important so uh bioinformatics is a
service we also get involved in high
impact projects so the nanopore projects
that we currently have now uh we have
bioinformaticians from our marketplace
working with uh the different partners
in the by the diplomax network so that's
how
diplomax handles bioinformatics as a
service
so speaking a little bit more about
bioinformatics and project design so 46
percent of projects fail because of poor
project design
why they did not properly consider the
needs for data analysis so if you want
to look at i'm just going to use an
analogy if you want to count how many
apples they are
that means that when you go to the
market you must get apples so that you
can count apples so some times when
you're designing a project what you need
is um replicates in order for you to
have confidence in your data and if you
don't put in
replicates at the beginning then you
will not have confidence in your data at
the end
it sounds like a very simple thing but
um
it's it's a it's a small gap between
like molecular biologists and
bioinformatics bioinformaticians so we
we strongly encourage that
bioinformaticians are involved at the
beginning of the project so some of the
efforts by diplomatics have been mainly
in awareness because when we do speak to
researchers or students
lightbulb sort of goes off where we talk
about you know project design um
so just spreading awareness that it is
important too or they they don't know
that you know it's something that they
should do to improve a band repetition
at the beginning when they're planning
out their project so awareness so last
year
i know this year we had a little
campaign where we released
some lighter advance just to say you
know patrick shows do it right the first
time so um as i was explaining some of
the projects that we've had that after
the data was already they were trying to
do patchwork where we're trying to roll
back and trying to get the best that we
can out of the
out of the data
and then another one is a project
without biased medics it's like a car
without wheels it's not going anywhere
so if your car does not have wheels it's
not going anywhere you can create your
project you can run the samples but
again if you don't if you want to count
apples you have to go and buy apples at
the market
um so this is also just an explanation
of how our marketplace works from a
brochure um
we sort of welcome you to it uh give you
why it's important explain our process
and then tell you what bioinformatics is
and then just say let's work together
okay and then bioinformatics training we
do this mainly through partners we found
that collaboration works well if we
don't have to reinvent the wheel we
won't they're already partners that are
doing it quite well um
and the aim really is to enable through
facilitating there are two main groups
that we are currently focusing on so
it's the bioinformaticians themselves
because maybe they may need to upskill
or get a new skill and the wetland
scientist um so
it is actually important for my
molecular biologists for example uh
to have an understanding of
bioinformatics so
we it might be good and well for us to
say they should include it at project
design but if they're also not aware of
you know downstream what needs to be in
place or how things work um then
although they know it's important they
don't know how to consider it so it's
also important to train even if it's
going to be a basic training of
bioinformatics even if they're not going
to do their bioinformatics by themselves
it's important for them to at least have
an idea of how everything works that way
then they can um
best engage a bioinformatician to get
the best out of them
they will for example already know that
when i meet my bio implementation these
are the things that we need to cover or
this is the critical information that i
need to give them so here's just two
examples of training um through our
partner at uh
thermofisher and training through
partnering with um icgb
okay and then we're going to talk about
few future bioinformaticians
i'm just checking my time i'm out of
time but i'm i'm going to be done soon
so future bioinformaticians so these are
high school outreaches so human capacity
development so we focus a lot on low
resource schools um just to stimulate
interest in science and negate quite a
lot of misconceptions they have about
science and also to give them exposure
to this so they might not even know
certain things are aware so we take them
through very high level um scientific
concepts and we end for example in them
doing like a mock chord and then i tell
them a little bit more about
bioinformatics and tell them all of the
other different science fields that are
involved from example from start
of uh strawberry dna extraction to the
end
all right and then we're going to go
into the last one which is artisan
biomed
this is mainly focused on precision
medicine um
so
one one way to think about is that all
of the research that is being done is in
order to inform solutions so artisan
sort of takes it from the step where
they're now
utilizing these solutions but they have
a focus on precision medicine and they
also have a focus on people of african
descent because as we know from research
african populations or genomes are
underrepresented in research so that's
why the focus is there and it also
better serves their population group in
south africa
um
so precision medicine gives better
insights to disease and that's another
reason um
why why artisans sort of focus into this
better insights into disease in
particular for people of african descent
because if
the research on people of african
descent is underrepresented it means
that the solutions that come out do not
best um serve them
so they also have a training arm to them
as well where they want to empower
clinicians and medical experts and
different stakeholders in precision
medicine
so here they're creating consume they're
creating sorry products for consumers
and clinicians
um
and it's usually a commercial product
so i'm just going to go into a little
bit more about the bioinformatics with
respect to artisan so it is going to be
the same skill set that we use for the
cpgr but you have to refine it to make a
commercial project so initially you're
you're making um you're using it for
researchers so usually like a plot is
the product that you're giving them or
data or a bar graph but with
artisan because it is a product that's
going to a client it means that if it's
going to be a report it's going to be a
more refined and commercial report so in
addition to the programming skills you
have to have additional skills that help
you make it a product so for example
additional skills can be outsourced and
easily integrated it could be a
user user experience experience
engineer who comes in
and
the additional skills as well are not
mostly non-computational so sometimes
you just need a clinical geneticist
who's going to come in better inform
your product
so the initial as i said the initial
considerations are similar to the cpgr
um the pipelines everything that you're
doing is centered towards a product
right so you have to make it easy to use
it has to be well documented it has to
be easy to update the speed and the
storage and the quality are critical so
it's very different from academic
research where for example if you're if
you have a variant caller you can use an
open source variant color that's going
to take two days to run because two days
in um
two year masters is not a significant
amount of time but if you have a client
using an open source two days is like
already too much someone is waiting for
their result so speed storage and
quality are critical
so
there's a wide range of products and
services
it's simple as a co-fit test and
although the testing may be simple
providing it as a service is what's
complex so i'm just going to give a
quick example of one of their products
which is be happy to be you it's the
most comprehensive ancestry test in
africa with an international client base
so it's forged thinking it's a
forward-thinking effort because they
would like to use the rich informative
data to give further insights to people
so i'm just going to go through that so
this is actually an extract from my
report which shows um
my ancestry so here the bioinformatics
considerations as i've mentioned before
are going to be you have to test it's
going to be a complex pipeline you have
to test it you have to manage quite a
lot of things computing power analysis
and all of those things
and then um
for the last slide you're going to try
to extract as much reusable information
as you can so eg with this
ancestry report because you're using the
gsn it has a lot of informative markers
you can use some of the pharmacogenomic
markers to then give insights on
drug usage that's related to for example
in this one covet
yeah so although it's um
the data that comes is
rich and informative and it's complex to
interpret and report artisan has done
has had such a great start by taking
time to understand all of these
complexities